vamos a hacer un ejercicio de
porcentajes y para eso escribiremos
una pregunta qué porcentaje
qué porcentaje de 16
es 4 y para esto ustedes pueden hacer
pausa en el vídeo e intentarlo por su
parte
y asumiendo que han hecho está este
intento por su parte vamos a pensar en
qué porcentaje por ciento de 16 es 4
para que esto pueda ser posible podemos
pensar en porcentaje por ciento
acuérdense cuánto de cada 100 y en este
caso si nuestro cien por ciento es 16
cuánto será 4 qué porcentaje representa
nosotros podemos pensar este porcentaje
de 16 como una fracción vamos a ver
cuánto es 4
de cada 16 qué porcentaje es este 4
dentro de los 16 y para esto está muy
sencillo si lo tenemos como fracción
podemos pensar en una versión
simplificada en una fracción
simplificada y podemos dividir tanto el
numerador como el denominador entre 44
entre 4 es igual a 1
16 entre 4 es igual a 4 y podemos decir
a sabes que el 4 es un cuarto de 16 y
será correcto sin embargo no estaremos
contestando nuestra pregunta que es el
porcentaje por ciento entonces cómo
podemos pensarlo aquí una manera muy
fácil para sacar el porcentaje va a ser
pensar que
para que yo llegue al 100% y de
multiplicar este 4
para que llegue a 100 pero de la misma
manera voy a multiplicar este numerador
por ese mismo número para no afectar la
fracción así es que si pensamos cuántas
veces es de multiplicar el 4 para llegar
a 100 pienso en 25 4 por 25 es igual a
100 de la misma manera que se multiplicó
uno por 25 tendré 25
y de esta manera ahora sé que 25 de cada
100 es equivalente a 4 de cada 16 por lo
tanto el porcentaje será 25% ya ven qué
fácil estuvo otra manera en la que
podemos pensarlo es simplemente tomar
nuestra fracción original y hacer la
división tendríamos la división de 4
entre 16 y de entrada sé que este 16 no
me caben 4 por lo que contestaré
que eso es igual
pero si puedo añadir el punto decimal
y añadir precisión a este número 4 con
decimales para poder hacer la división
mucho más exacta 4 entre 16 fue este 0 0
por 16 0
4 - 0 es igual a 4 y puedo bajar el 1er
pero que se encuentra en la posición de
las décimas recuerden que este decimal
nos da pauta para saber que a la derecha
tenemos las décimas centésimas milésimas
bajo entonces el cero de las décimas 40
entre 16 me cabe dos veces porque 2 por
16 es igual a 32 y sea 40 el resto 32
tendré 8
ahora puedo bajar el siguiente cero
vamos a hacer un poco más de espacio
porque esto está muy apretado
ok ya hice un poco más de espacio
borraré entonces aquí el 8
y lo colocaré aquí abajo porque se 40 el
resto 32 tendré 8
ahora vamos a bajar con el anaranjado el
siguiente 0
80 entre 16 me cabe 5 veces 5 por 16 es
igual a 80 se 80 el resto 80 tendré como
residuos 0 y ahora estamos completos
tengo 0.25 o lo que es igual 25
centésimas y estas 25 centésimas las
podemos representar como 25 como
numerador y el 100 como denominador lo
que es igual 25 centésimas es igual a 25
% y de esta manera tenemos por dos
mecanismos que 4 es igual
25 % de 16 nos vemos en otro vídeo